قرار المجلس الاقليمي في خرسون ان القوات
الروسيه اوقفت عملها في المبنى الحكومي
الرئيسي في مدينه خرسون واشارت مصادر
محليه الى ان عدد القوات الروسيه في
المدينه انخفض في الاونه الاخيره مع نقل
بعض اهليتها الى ضفه نهر دمرو الجنوبيه
بدفعات صغيره وقلت مصادر رسميه الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه تواصل تفكيك المنشات
والمعدات الطبيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها صدقت محاولات
هجوم اوكرانيه في خيرسون وافادتها السلطات
المواليه لروسيا في خيرسون باعتراض مجموعه
من الصواريخ اطلقتها القوات الاوكرانيه
باتجاه المقاطعه مشيره الى ان خطوط الدفاع
الروسيه ليست في وضع حرجا حسب تعبيرها
ابو ليلى هنا في الاستديو اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
قراءتك دكتور لما يجري في خير سون الان
يعني هو جاء نتيجه طبيعيه لما جرى خلال
الاشهر الماضيه منذ خساره كياب ومن ثم
خارج كيف ازيوم الايمان وغيرها
اجبرت القوات الروسيه بعد هذه النكاسات
على تبني الدفاع لانها فقدت المباده
والقدره على الاستمرار في التعرض ومما اكد
ذلك الدعوه للتعبئه الجزئيه لهذا السبب
نجدها لجات الى التبني الدفاع وتحدثنا عن
معركه خرسون وقلنا الروس يميل الى
تسليم هذه المنطقه والانسحب منها ولكن ليس
بدون ثمن لهذا السبب نجدهم الان سواء في
خير او في المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه
تقريبا العمل متقارب قاموا بتبني الدفاع
وبناء عده خطوط دفاعيه تستند الى حقول
الغرام والى موانع اسمديه وخنادق ضد
الدبابات كذلك اضاف بعد اضافي جديد وهو
المسجد ما بين نوعين من الدفاع الدفاع
الثابت والدفاع النشط والدفاع
للقوات الروسيه
اوراق الخسارات تعلو على اوراق الربح في
خرسون وبالتالي لا يعطي ان تسلمها
بالمجان وبدون خوز معركه معركه استهزاف
انا اسميتها في فتره معركه كسر العظم من
اجل الحاق اكبر خسائر ممكن بالقوات
الاخرانيه لماذا لانه اذا قامت بالانسحاب
دون الدخول في معركه حاسمه هذا يعني ان
القوات الاوكرانيه المهاجمه لا تزال تترك
المبادئه لا تزال تمتلك القدره على تطوير
عملياتها قد تعبر نهر النيبر الى الضفه
الجنوبيه ونبدا نتحدث عن معارك في عمري
منطقه خرسون لهذا سبب اقول لك لجات الى
المسجد بين الدفاع الثابت والدفاع النشط
والذي يقوم اصلا على شانها جماعه معاكس
محدوده من اجل ايقاع الخسائر وتحديد ولكن
لصالح من اطاله امد المعركه
روسيا لماذا لماذا لانه اولا كلما طال امد
المعركه كل ما تغيرت الظروف وبعض هذه
الظروف تتغير لصالح القوات الروسيه على
سبيل المثال دخول فصل الشتاء القوات
المتعرضه جميع القوات تعاني ولكن القوات
المتحركه والتي تقوم بالعمليات التعرضيه
تعاني اكثر من القوات الثابته الامر الاخر
سئ تم حشد همم 40,000 جندي في بعض
التقارير روسيه شمال غرب النهار وبالتالي
هذا يعني هناك 100,000 جندي اوكراني هؤلاء
ال 100,000
لم يتم انهاءكم وايقاع عن نسبه كبيره همم
من الخسائر بين صفوفهم سواء بالافراد او
الاليات سيكون لديهم القدره على تطوير
العمليات وعبور نهر الدنافر من خلال
النبي تفضلت به ما هو المطلوب الان من
القوات الاوكرانيه القوات الاوكرانيه انا
اتحدث قبل اسبوعين عندما تحدث بان الفتره
الحاسمه نهايه شعر نوفمبر قلت هذا يتعارض
مع المنطق العسكري لان
عامل الزمن لا يعمل لصالح القوات
الاوكرانيه الا اذا كانت غير جاهزه للتعرض
الشامل اذا كان جاهزه عليها ان تنفذ
العمليه باسرع وقت ممكن تجنبا لايه امور
قد تغير قراءه شكرا لك